MARK MCDONALD: Hi, and welcome
to Google Developers Live.
I'm Mark McDonald, and
I'm with Josh Livni
here from the Maps
Developer Relations team.
Today we're going to start
talking about Google Maps
Engine and a couple
of new features
we've got on the endpoints.
Over to you, Josh.
JOSH LIVNI: Thanks Mark.
Yeah, so Google Maps Engine,
some of you might be familiar,
is a kind of easy way to create,
share, publish maps, and put
data into a Google Cloud.
So what we're going
to cover today
are a couple of
endpoints that create
and upload endpoints to show
you how to programmatically get
data in, and why don't we
start off by looking at a demo.
MARK MCDONALD: So
this first demo
is a Python sample that's hosted
using Google's App Engine.
We'll load it up straight
away and get straight into it.
We start off with
looking at some projects
that you'll have
attached to your account,
so you can group your
different mapping projects
into logical groupings
called projects.
With this demo, we simply
just upload a shapefile.
A shapefile is a
zip file of a bunch
of sort of component
files that form
some vector data
in a table format.
We can provide a
description and some tags
to describe our table if
we want to find it later
using the APIs, and then we can
just go ahead and upload it.
JOSH LIVNI: OK, so
it turns out this
is probably not about kittens.
We'll just put state
borders, hit Upload, and what
will happen in the
back end here is
we're creating a sort
of skeleton asset,
saying what files are going
to be involved in the upload,
uploading the individual
files, and then
getting back a status
for Maps Engine,
which we can see on the screen.
MARK MCDONALD: Once
that status is processed
and we're ready to go,
we'll get a link showing us
on the page, which can send
us back to the Maps Engine web
interface, where we'll be able
to get a preview of the vector
data that's been uploaded.
As you can see here, there's
a couple little blue outlines,
which show the data
that we did upload.
Everything's been successful.
So that's all good.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah,
and if I go ahead
and refresh this
page over here, we
should see that the
processing status is complete.
It usually takes a few seconds,
gives us some metadata back
about the data that we uploaded.
So that's the kind
of example that you
might want to build so that
people can use your workflow
to get the data in.
This code is available
on it GitHub.
You can download it at the
link below, fork it, modify it,
use it as a starting point
for working with App Engine
and OAuth and the syntax for
uploading data to Maps Engine.
MARK MCDONALD: And if
you've got any opportunities
for improvement that you
think we'd like to know about,
feel free to send them our way.
We love getting pull requests.
JOSH LIVNI: Indeed we do.
So let's go ahead and
walk through a little bit
more detail the code and kind
of the flow of getting data
in with this second example
here, which you can download
as part of our Python
Client Library.
So if you go and look for
the Google API Python Client,
there's a bunch of samples.
And in the samples, there's
a Maps Engine sample
that we'll walk through.
You can just download the
zip or clone the project
to get this sample.
MARK MCDONALD: So on the first
run with a sample like this,
it would walks
through an OAuth flow,
just to find out
who you are and make
sure you've got permission
to access the data.
We'll skip straight past
that, but before you
get started on your
own project, even
if you're running
this sample, you'll
need to go ahead
and get an API key
and set up a project
on Google's API console
before you'll be
able to start this.
There's more docs on
developers.google.com,
or you can ask in the comments.
JOSH LIVNI: Excellent.
So as part of setting up that
developer console project,
you'll get an API key,
and you can at that point
download the
client_secrets, which
you can see that I have put
into my samples folder here.
That's client_secrets.json.
And once I have that in there, I
can go ahead and run my sample.
And what it will do is
create an authorized request
to the project's endpoint, get
me back a list of projects.
I'm going to pick a
project here like this one
that I have access to,
get the ID of the project,
and pass that in as an
argument, projects argument.
Run the script
again, and what you
can see flying by
you on the screen
up here is this skeleton
asset that we're creating.
It's going through now,
uploading each file
individually down here, and
then pulling for the processing
status to see how
that upload is doing.
MARK MCDONALD: And that's
exactly the same process
that we went through
in the previous demo,
just on the command line.
JOSH LIVNI: Right.
And now that we have a
little 5-second wait here,
it would say successfully
processed, give us the table ID
back.
And now why don't we go
ahead and take a look
at the actual code.
MARK MCDONALD: When Josh
first ran the program earlier,
it was just a list project,
which basically just
uses this simple get request
of this URL you can see below.
It's as simple as it looks.
It is a get request.
We don't need any parameters.
We just take the JSON
response that comes back
from the server, and we log
it straight to the output.
Once we've done that, we
want to upload our shapefile,
so that was the second
run through that Josh did.
It takes the upload URL below,
which is a /tables endpoint.
And basically, before we
can start uploading data,
we need to create an
empty table asset.
So down here, we go through
each of the shapefile suffixes
that we're going to
use, which are mapped
to each of the corresponding
shape component files that
are in the zip file we used
and create an empty metadata
structure, which
describes the table
that we're about
to start uploading.
Once we push this
to the server, we
get back an ID which
corresponds to the table
that we're going to
use to upload content
when we do each
of the shapefiles
and also when we go to
pull the server later.
So then we go straight into the
file suffixes and upload them
straight to the
endpoint we used before,
just with a /files on the end,
and push those files straight
up to the server.
Once that's done, we
use the ID we got back
from the original request
to check on the table status
and make sure that
everything's all good.
JOSH LIVNI: Awesome.
Thanks for the walkthrough.
That looks pretty
straightforward.
Just to summarize
it, we're going
to go ahead and go through
the OAuth workflow, which
happens like magic in the
Python samples for you.
But we end up with an
authorized HTTP request,
and then we go ahead and post
a sort of skeleton asset, which
says these are the files
we're going to be putting in,
these are the different
tags, description,
and name of the project.
And once we post that,
we get back an ID.
We use that ID to go ahead and
push the various files in, pole
for the processing
status, and we're done.
And the cool thing is,
this works very similarly
for images.
So, for example,
if you're uploading
a georeferenced image, you can
have that PNG, for example,
in the sidecar file that
has the world extent
and do the exact same pattern.
A couple other
details, like you might
be including some
additional things
like that date of the image,
but generally the same pattern.
And then in addition, we
have a create endpoint,
so you can create an
empty vector table
without having to have an
existing shapefile, or CSV,
or KML or anything like
that, and then just push data
into it later using
the insert endpoint.
So go ahead and check
out these code samples.
MARK MCDONALD: Yeah,
they're available on GitHub,
and if you've got any
questions about it,
you can either ask
in the comments
or jump on StackOverflow.
There's a big community
of users there
who are happy to help
you out, and good luck.
If you have any more
questions, I guess,
there's documentation
we can check out
on developers.google.com.
But have fun.
JOSH LIVNI: Cheers,
guys, until next time.